تحمي هذه القلعة ، التي تطفو على البحر الأبيض المتوسط
ينة ساحلية قديمة لم
ات السنين ، وهي أيضًا مكان تك
نفه الأسطورة حيث قا
لت أميرة أسطورية مصيرًا معينًا على بعد حوالي 700
دم من ساحل جنوب تر
يا.  جزيرة صغيرة للغاية تبدو
وكأنها تقف على الماء ،
ويعود تاريخ أسوار وأبراج القلعة إلى
أوائل القرن الثاني عشر ، على الرغم من أن من قام
ببنائها هو لغز وفقًا لإحدى
الأساطير ، قام الملك البيزنطي ببناء القلعة
بعد أن أخبره أحد العرافين بذلك.
ستموت ابنته الوحيدة من لدغة ثعبان
على الرغم من جهود الملك لحماية
الأميرة ثعبان تسلل إلى الداخل من خلال الاختباء في سلة فواكه
، وقابلت الأميرة
جدرانها المحصنة المصيرية الملتفة
حول المجمع بأكمله مع ثمانية
أبراج توفر مناظر 360 درجة مما
يجعل  القلعة خط دفاع أول فعال
ضد سفن العدو التي تقترب
من الميناء قد تكون أسطورة القرن الثاني عشر
شيئًا من الماضي ولكن
لا تزال إحدى جدران القلعة قائمة حتى اليوم
محتفظة بأسرارها
[موسيقى]